uh we talked about this a little bit but
um okay you did a whole album with hit
maker he has had a friendly Feud we'll
call it it's I like it because I think
it kind of you know lets people talk
about producers yeah yeah you know with
Hit Boy they're two very different guys
so different hit boys obviously touching
the beat he's sequencing the drums he's
you put NPC in front of Hit Boy he knows
yeah you know what I mean I look at hit
make it as more like um
like a like a 90s type producer where
like the way Diddy is a producer yeah or
the way like Quincy Jones he knows how
to get the people Rick Rubin yeah get
the right people in the room get the
right writers in the room kind of
conduct a hit record uh what are your
thoughts on this whole thing yeah hit
point hit makeup ah man
I think when you talk about that music
that's it you know what I'm saying like
hit maker is you know conducting the
session and hit boy is literally
producing and musically engineering the
session
but hit Maker's argument wasn't about
the talent when it comes to musicianship
he was just like
I'm on the radio you know that was
always the argument was so to his
argument he won the argument you know I
mean but to hit boys argument he's not
even tripping on the radio I don't think
he's trying to be on the radio he's not
and also for the record I mean this
guy's done yeah yeah that song is still
you know and hitmaker is only about your
current right now this is what we
talking about but hit boy is like yo I'm
planting seeds you know for the
generations to come to discover my music
not for sure and he's like uh the the
nausea is crazy to me yeah yeah that's
he typed in that's what I'm saying
yeah the music album he's going he's
going crazy and and and different styles
you know influencing a generation of
making beats like that can't go
undermined have you ever worked with hit
boy yeah a couple times what was the
difference kind of I guess student Vibe
was
um so with Hit Boy it was a much slower
process of like Tech our time like let's
listen let's let's see what we got let's
see how we feeling and with hitmaker
he's Speedy Gonzalez in the studio what
we got next one okay you got an idea
okay next one okay next one and he's a
next one next one next one in three
hours you got five songs he's worrying
about it tomorrow what we doing tomorrow
and then a week later he has 30 songs to
place artists come through the studio
hey what you've been working on he has
30 options to play you know what I'm
saying so it's like it's a factory that
he's intentionally doing as opposed to
his boy he's selective who he's working
with you know I mean and you know it's
more of like a like a it's almost like
because I've been in the studio I've
been in the studio where they make us
for a sec but hit boy is very like
intentional and it's yeah if you're
gonna go over to chalice and work with
him like block out the night
exactly exactly we chilling we're gonna
have a loop on we might fall in love
with something and then he might be like
hold on let me switch the idea start
something over because you know the
foundation is music and you know I just
think they they they they they they re
they stand for different things but they
both represent the same thing ahead and
they're both very good at what they do
yes sir at a high level
um
like when you get with hit make it
because I feel do you feel like
you guys are like his Factory process
I feel like you're you're a kind of a
go-to asset for him in terms of like
when you're laying hooks down for him do
you know that they're just they might
end up somewhere else yeah for sure for
sure because he's shopping them actively
with your hook on it to the artist the
media he was like yo uh I got Ty coming
by this week I got this beat I need you
on it this one it got your name all over
it boom I come through bless
such a great song by the way that album
is super slept on yeah my tie the mai
tai album was [__] raw that's what
made me be like oh no no I'm going over
there we about to work what's up uh
Krishan what's up uh hit maker what's up
uh Source you know and when you link up
with them and you can add your own
flavor I think that's when you'll be
able to differentiate yourself and keep
your uniqueness uh I also think Jeremiah
is another one of the yeah great
songwriters of our time who don't get
enough credit in that aspect I agree I
agree I think he's another person that's
not really tripping on like
the fame the bright lights the music
videos like the tours like he's just
like man I look I'm from Chicago I love
making music and all the [__] that I'm
spitting is real and the real [__]
connect with it and that's it and you
know I think that keeps his core and his
solid foundation stable